[Musique]
pour ce faire les petits ce soir je vais
vous apprendre une recette de cuisine
inde où je suis sûr que ça vous plaira
en avant chef cuisinier nounours défend
et et marmites sont les seuls
propos probables
[Musique]
bonsoir le grand chef cuisinier la chica
là on va faire de la cuisine
de la grande cuisine
j'espère qu'on va faire des crêpes rui
de craie ballon ce soir je vais vous
faire beaucoup mieux à plat un doux 1 à
carrizo c'est quoi un hack ariza c'est
un doux et c'est bon tu fais une
passerelle non j'ai besoin d'une grande
mare bits comme celle-là des cuillères
et vous allez voir ce que vous allez
voir voilà j installe mon matériel voilà
je vais au fond de la marmite de l'huile
de sésame
3 galettes de sarrasin puisque nous
sommes 3 500 noir tu également ce sont
des galettes hindous et après jacques
joint du riz avec sa part une passe tu
sais le marin veilleux nicolas laisse
faire le gros chat merci et à présent
les sauces les fameuses sondes de la
rouge qui piquent de la douce aux
pétales de roses de l'aveyron gengembre
et puis une pointe de cannelle de la
noix muscade des rages à 1 sec de la
citronnelle et du field hirondelles
ne vous a patienté pas vous allez
bientôt pouvoir goûter
mélangeons
mélenchon une hausse là et voilà la
capitale preuve
ses secrets quand c'est moi c'est ma
main c'est délicieux je vous comprends
pas mon appétit
à ça je ne comprends pas
ma place ce que sera ou non
mon
pauvre nounours je tombe pas malade
que c'était bon j'ai tout mangé pato qui
soit aussi grand a je ne suis pas bon je
me porte bien
soir one lance bien portants boîte de
nuit petit pas prenait lé petit nicolas
g et alain
[Musique]
adam un grand chef
allons en route cuisinier patron est ce
que je suis très gros mais non mon gros
ne nous envoyer plein vol nuit les
enfants ont embrassé bien fort vos
parents est faite de port 1
[Musique]
ans